so what time is it
it's early on easter sunday morning we
remember that
inferno started on good friday morning
and then proceeded through friday night
and holy saturday what rest there was
was the kind of rest you get in hell
maybe as the old saying goes a bad night
in a bad motel something like that
when dante and virgil emerge now at the
beginning of purgatorio
it is into this new day
and to this moment near dawn on easter
sunday
it's interesting to think by the way of
the inferno as a journey that takes
place
across holy saturday students of course
love to point out that dante's quest
resembles
one of their more uh frequent
and frequently lamented practices the
all-nighter
so when dante and virgil emerge um
it's after that journey and now finally
on the shores of purgatory
let's jump in to canto one and notice a
few things together
i will sing about that second realm
given the human soul
to purge its sin and grow worthy to
climb to paradise
hear rise to life again dead
poetry this beautiful
striking opening so probably the most
interesting line is that last one though
hear rise to life again dead poetry
and i wish someone had told me at least
a little bit earlier
that we were reading dead poetry but we
learn about it now
or so it seems it's not entirely clear
what that line means
at a minimum here on easter sunday
morning
poetry itself is going to rise to new
life
no more poetry of death no more poetry
of despair
no more poetry of the lost
while the poem is certainly about the
state of souls after death
and these three parts of eternity
it's also about the present moment it's
about the here and now
and so one of the great fruits of the
poem is to help
us the readers in the present moment of
our lives
in our present duties in the here and
now
one of the things dante does better than
anyone
is to help give the reader a
perspective on life that's
reliable and trustworthy and helpful
it's very easy to lose perspective in
life it's very easy to
have a skewed perspective and what dante
does is he gives us
an eternal perspective on the soul
on freedom on love on god and that's one
of the greatest gifts
any teacher could give to a student any
poet
to a reader any artist to an audience
the beginning of dante's purgatory